dea
アメリカではバイオハザードの映画は好評でとても人気があるっていうような
マーケティングを日本であっている
しかし現実は同7アメリカではバイオハザードの評価をどうなんだろう
biohazard the 沿いんだろう
最後でよかった
ムービー dx のクリススタック
脚本をゾンビが書いたのではハリウッドリポーターのフランクシェックシリーズの最も
酷い作品
ニューヨークタイムズのグレーン系にそうだしリス立ったほかの作品の評価も見て
みよう
バイオハザード1まったくの時間の無駄だ
シカゴサンタイムズのリチャードローパバイオハザード2
ただ
the お金を動かすために作られた作品この映画はデッドゾーンだ
創造的な発想もなければ面白い特集効果もない歩行者にご注意
もしこの映画が好きだという子どもがいたらそいつを自分の子供からすぐに突き放し
ダサい
シカゴサンタイムズのロジャー e part 世界中の映画評論家の評価を総括する
ウェブサイト
トロットのトマトでは6作品の平均スコアは100点満点の29点だ
食べ物に例えると床に落ちたマックのチーズバーガーちなみにまずの卓球でも96点千
と千尋は97
ミシュランの三つ星へここがポイントゲームのほうはサバイバルホラーという新しい
ジャンルを作った超名作であるその
超名作をハリウッドが解剖して魂のない最悪の映画シリーズに4
今度はソニーピクチャーズがそれを映画化された日本作品としてここ日本で
マーケティングをした
しかもより多くの人を引き寄せるために今ではローラが流暢な英語劇中で披露などと
いういかにも安っぽいテーマで使っている
まるで白の対処が握った大トロを見てマックが常に人工ケチャップをつけて
それを寿司と呼んで日本人に食わせているようだ原作を作った三上真司さんに会うこと
あれば土下座して謝りたいわねっても日本人よりアメリカ人の方が見てるじゃん当然
だろうアメリカ人のほとんどはファーストフード付きだからしかし料理人で
バイオハザードが良い方という人はほとんどいない要は無理かの村国とトカゲの
こちらは日本でもアメリカでもバカにされるがん協会の中をハーレーで走り回るアリス
は日本では馬鹿にされない
それどころかかっこいいアクションヒロインと呼ばれる
同じだバカにしてくださいでないと3人後にまた腐ったカリフォルニアロールが果たさ
れるから
biohazard the last 復讐にマギカてるんだって
見に行くラフィもラーズ
フェンスや本いうのも帰りでいいわんん
ni
[音楽]